[Music]
today we welcome a very special guest
who hails from India born in a
predominantly Hindu and Shake Nation the
odds of becoming a Christian were slim
to none having experienced the truth of
Christ in his life he comes to shed
light on two interconnected practices
yoga and Hinduism we welcome Ivan Raj to
a wolf in sheep's clothing thank you so
much for coming thank you so much for
having me on the show I have to admit
this is probably going to be one of my
my most favorite moments in this series
because this is where my trap was yoga
not knowing it was Hinduism but before
we get to that I want to know about your
upbringing absolutely so uh I was
actually raised in a Christian home uh
my mom was also a Christian and my
grandparents were also a Christian on my
mom's side on my dad's side uh the
grandparents were my grandparents were
uh Hindus MH and uh my my grandparents
on my mom's side raised me and my
brother so theologically for the
audience at home who doesn't really know
the difference between Christianity
Christianity excuse me and Hinduism
could you break that down for them oh
yeah that's a very good question there's
a lot of differences in fact everything
is different uh between Hinduism and
Christianity so Hinduism is salvation by
works and if I may correct my statement
there is nothing called as salvation per
se in Hinduism I say that because um
there is there's no proper definition of
sin and there are no
Commandments in Hinduism truth so in
Christianity we have Commandments if you
break the law of God it's sin and
therefore we need a savior so there is
no savior there is no need for savior in
Hinduism you void Christ Al together so
in Hinduism uh people do okay
so Hindus do worship Christ some Hindus
worship Christ he's one among the 300
million gods and
goddesses and um so they just uh you
know Place Christ uh picture in their um
um worship yeah exactly altar is the
right word yes we call it Puja room Puja
room is worship room or altar as you can
say uh so he his picture is uh you know
framed and placed next to other gods and
goddesses yes and they people bow you
know Hindus bow before that and worship
so he's basically iconic and and kind of
revered as a teacher and and equalized
to say Gandhi or Buddha or something of
that that is correct yes so actually in
in U you know some of the Tamil movies
or South Indian movies they used to show
uh Buddha Jesus and Gandhi's uh you know
three pictures next to each other and
make Jesus equal to Gandhi and Buddha
blasphemy so tell us was there pressure
from say your Hindu family or Hindu
Society uh because you guys were
Christian uh well I was growing up we
didn't have uh that much of pressure but
uh I was exposed to Hinduism early on
because I was studying in a Hindu school
I studied in a Hindu school for some
years and that actually got me a good
exposure of uh Hinduism now Hinduism is
a very broad
term um so the actual word for people
who follow that type of uh practice that
is idolatry
and nature worship uh they were called
as Hindus um so that religion is called
as sanatana Dharma uh sanatana means
Eternal Dharma means law so Eternal law
so Hinduism has two tracks or two paths
one is atheistic the other one is
theistic so in the atheistic form of
Hinduism people worship nature and I was
put in a school where nature worship was
the way to go and on the other hand
there is a theistic form of Hinduism
where people worship you know statues
and they they have their own rituals and
so forth but whether you worship nature
or you wor worship a statue it's still
idolatry it is still idolatry absolutely
yes and so when did you get exposed to
yoga in in your walk in life so uh in my
school days uh I think I was um maybe
six seven years old and uh uh maybe no
not six seven I'm sorry probably eight
nine years old and uh in my Hindu School
in that Hindu School uh they taught us
to chant
mantras and uh now in in that aspect of
Hinduism right the the the theistic
sorry the atheistic aspect of Hinduism
um it's all about chanting it's all
about chanting because they believe that
God is in the nature and pantheism
basically so my exposure was since then
chanting the Hindu mantras and also
exposure to yoga through that so
chanting these mantras what do they
actually do for you so it is supposed to
bring good energy it is supposed to make
you feel good it doesn't necessarily um
help in character transformation or
character
Reformation uh but it's supposed to help
you feel good which are principles and
the laws that Christ put before us
exactly right so the transcripts that
the The Ten Commandments are a
transcript of his character yeah and we
are to emulate him empty ourselves and
allow his character to come inside of us
yes so yes the Bible teaches us that we
have to become like Christ character
transformation right so that doesn't
happen in chanting uh en chanting
basically it is
to bring the Divinity that is within the
human to bring it out because we're
supposed to be Gods we just don't know
it yet correct and so once we bring out
this God what is the goal so once you
bring out the god uh from within you
then you you will be reincarnated you
will be reborn uh so they teach that
once a person dies the body goes back
but then the thoughts will remain and
it'll continue and it'll be
reincarnated um as a human or as an
animal so that's what Hinduism teaches
on the other hand Buddhism which came
out of Hinduism because gutama Buddha
left Hinduism and he started as religion
right so Buddhism teaches about
rebirth I say Buddhism I'm referring to
Buddhism now because even Buddhism also
talks about yoga similar principalities
similar principles yeah so when you know
you see people doing yoga in America is
it the same as the yoga that you find in
India um I would say now it's becoming
same mhm which is why many people many
Christians when they practice yoga after
a certain point of time they abandon
Christianity and they become Hindus and
I also see them kind of synchronizing
them you know with this uh Buddha
Consciousness along with the Christ cons
Consciousness and also contemplative
prayer could you touch on that so
contemplative prayer um so when we when
we look into you know
chanting um it's a similar to that where
the mind is focused on a certain thing
and uh so so so in in in yoga there are
like eight limbs right so one of the
limb is called danana danana means
meditation and uh Diana is to focus on a
certain object maybe a Mandela yes an
object in nature an object or the person
can also close their eyes and focus
inward Focus inward or I was start to
actually Focus or imagine the melting uh
candle interesting yeah so so instead of
being the light you're supposed to just
let it melt yes so there's no need for a
communication so in in prayer praying to
Jesus Christ praying to the father
through Jesus Christ there is a
communication that happens there's
two-way communic there's dialogue that
happen that should happen because if we
don't hear God's voice then we have a
problem in relationship with God that's
right all of us should hear God's voice
indeed um so God wants to talk to us and
he wants us to talk to him so there is a
relationship
uh it's a relationship based um you know
uh uh religion uh Christian true
Christianity right there's a person
there is God yeah there's a there's a
personal God yes and on the other hand
in Hinduism that's not how it is um you
don't need a god of course so basically
you just pray look within yourself and
you just focus on something or someone
and however you're impressed is the way
the day is divided yes so let's get to
the actual form of yoga I know that
there's many T types there's laughing
yoga there's goat yoga does it really
make a
difference so some people in the west
have noticed that some people do such uh
you know terms they use those
terminologies goat yoga beer yoga also
so there are different terminologies
that people use and they attach the word
yoga but I think they're doing it for
fun however it offends the Hindus it's
offensive to it's offensive the Hindus
because in Hinduism it's a sacred uh
ritual yoga is a Hindu sacred ritual
it's a Hindu ritual what I've noticed as
well in my own research is that yoga
wasn't just something that anyone in the
masses could do that there are ranks
within the culture in India and so there
are certain people maybe Banis is that
what they're called the the I guess the
most powerful knowledgeable of the
that understand the yoga sutras the
bagita and all these things and that it
was a reserved practice for the almost
high priest within that culture yes I
think you're referring to cast system
cast system exactly so the high priests
or the priests who are part of the
higher highest cast of in Hinduism uh so
they are called brahin the Brahman cast
and uh um yeah so so it used to be
practiced by brahans uh because uh even
till today you know they use the mantras
which are which are from Sanskrit
language uh so even now in the west also
a lot of people use Sanskrit
terminology uh like for example Namaste
is a Sanskrit term and uh so there are
several Sanskrit terms Sanskrit is an
ancient language and uh and all of the
Hindu scriptures uh are written uh in in
Sanskrit there are also certain other
Hindu scriptures which are written in
another language called Tamil South
Indian language Tam Tamil s yeah t m i l
10 okay so I noticed also that you know
Christians practice in it and they say
it's just exercise can Hinduism yoga and
the practice of yoga be
separated okay so I'm going to answer
both of your questions so uh yoga is one
of the six schools of Hindu teachings
it's called as dashans dashan means view
uh six views of Hinduism out of that one
of the view is Yoga one of the views is
yoga and yoga is atheistic in nature
atheistic in nature why do you say that
is atheistic because uh you don't need a
personal God you have to bow down before
the sun Su son or you can look within
yourself uh to find answers for life
it's movement that's what people will
say it's just move it it's just
stretching no no it's not just
stretching uh because in when we when we
take Sun salutation right so in the west
it's called Sun salutation the actual
term is Surya namaskara Surya means Sun
namaskara means worship so actually Sun
worship but they label it as salutation
and they sold it to the West so in Sun
salutation there are 12 postures anybody
uh any of our viewers can look this up
and 12 postures are all about stretching
right however each of the stretches they
have a meaning to it
there is a meaning and the meaning is
about praising the son invoking the son
God and uh inviting the son to bless
such type of um phrases but the chant is
in
Sanskrit nobody chants in English nobody
chants in Spanish the chant is in
Sanskrit language so when we look into
the Sanskrit meanings for all of the 12
postures it tells about Sun worship so
when you were talking about how you're
going to answer both questions we've
covered the spiritual part of it can it
be separate can yoga itself be separated
can I practice as a Christian and keep
it benign no because uh yoga the
stretches the postures are a physical
expression of
worship I understand very well that
there are certain postures few
postures uh in a grand scheme of things
few postures uh can also be done by a
non- yogic practitioner like a regular
as a regular stretch for example plank
posture right it's part of the sun
worship Sun salutation but planks uh can
be it's more like a transition it's not
necessarily a deity right which one
plank uh the plank posture in yoga
context in the context of yoga it it is
actually praising the sun still yes in
context of yoga okay and that is why
there's a sequence so there are 12
postures in Sun salutation or sun
worship as per yoga and uh each posture
is has a so it has a sequence the 12
poses they have a sequence nobody will
change the sequence because that is how
it is set so an isolated plank pose not
within the context or sequence of yoga
is okay yes it is it's harmless yes
correct um because in yoga there is
sequence for all the postures and the
sequence is intentional because because
it is a part of the worship it is a
worship it's a reenactment of the myth
it is a react re not in Sun worship not
in the not in Sun
salutation but there are other postures
like for example there is Warrior 1
Warrior 2 Warrior 3 that is a
reenactment of a murdered scene uh
according to Hindu mythology so that is
reenacted as a posture the the murder SC
actually the beheading scene in Hindu
mythology is enacted as Warrior 1 2 3
now you created a a beautiful uh series
of information called yoga andbox which
we're going to cover in the next episode
but I want to just take us back into
your upbringing you mentioned that as a
Christian you were required to go to a
Hindu school did that continue The
Duality yeah so it did continue for some
some years and uh it's interesting I
also want to mention that in Hinduism
The Unlucky day of the week is a seventh
day what yeah so uh we were you know we
were asked to chant on the seventh day
on the on Saturday
mornings and um so we'll be chanting to
reverse the the um unluckiness so to
speak almost a curse yeah to reverse
that to positive so the gift of of God
the Sabbath with which points to Jesus
yeah is unlucky and it's a curse yes yes
so it is called shenar in Hindi language
and uh and uh it means it's it's a day
which is the most unluckiest so we used
to chant on Saturday so we used to be
trained during the week days like Monday
through Friday uh we used to have a
class uh where we learned a little bit
of Sanskrit and the chanting uh but no
one taught us a meaning though of the
those chance and then we'll have to
recite it on stage in front of the whole
school um the the chance on Saturday
mornings so it's important to mention
that India is a pretty large place
there's many different languages many
different cultures Sanskrit is very
specific correct yes Sanskrit is a very
ancient language there's also another
language called Tamil which is a very
ancient language uh but all of the
mantras the chants are in s Sanskrit
that is being taught that are being
taught in the west it's a Sanskrit
language and so although you're being
taught this like you said you don't
understand the definition you don't know
that you're blaspheming the god that you
now serve yeah at that time I did not
know because the meanings were not
taught yeah so how did this change
happened for you where you committed to
Christ and left alone the hind Faith
sure absolutely so uh we were uh
introduced to the Adventist Faith uh the
way we were introduced were because my
mom had a lot of of questions from the
Bible my grandfather my mom's dad dad he
also has had a lot of questions so we
were invited to a certain meeting which
was actually conduct actually presented
by um um uh pastor Dwight Nelson he's in
Michigan yes and uh so he came down to
Chennai city was born and raised in
India and so the one of the organizers
for those meetings were was my distant
relative my relative and uh so he
invited us to just see him but we
couldn't get to see him so my mom and I
we sat outside the auditorium but they
had speakers outside the auditorium so
we heard his messages that day and even
though we didn't meet my relative the
organizer one of the organizers we my
mom decided that she has to come back
the next day also and she took a lot of
notes and she brought it to my
grandfather he was 76 at the time and uh
so he verified the notes in English with
his Telugu Bible Telugu is another
language a South Indian language and
then he verified and he found that
everything that this man was preaching
was according to the Bible and he was
amazed that he was he found answers for
his questions in the in his Bible
providential providential yeah and so
also my mom as well so we became
Adventists uh in in 1993 I believe in
1993 we became Adventist so when we
became Adventist that exposed us to the
Bible
so is this where the passion for you
know demystifying yoga is that where
it's rooted in so uh not at that time I
did not have uh I should say I didn't
have a proper relationship with God at
that time growing up uh but about
um N9 years ago 9 10 years ago that's
when I was drawn to work for the Lord
and surrender my life to L to L Lord's
hands and um about five six years ago
the the lord gave uh Lord gave me some
information or showed me some
information um through the length of the
Bible and current events so I started
presenting uh at different churches a
series of talks titled India in
eschatology India's role in the end
times before the Advent of Christ so I
used to go to different churches where I
get invited I used to go and present
these talks and at that time I had just
only one slide for yoga just one slide
and I used to ask the audience question
hey who is the author and finisher of
your faith and the audience will because
they're Christians Adventists they'll
say is Jesus Christ but who is the
author and finisher of yoga not Jesus
Christ no so how can we do yoga so that
is that's all I used to ask about yoga
but later on the Lord showed more and
more information about yoga a lot of
information about yoga so then uh so
that one slide became multiple slides it
became one whole talk and then now it's
become a series of uh of presentations
called yoga unboxed which we'll get to
in the next episode yeah and initially I
did not want to share it with people I I
thought I'll send my slides to uh a few
Adventist preachers and they can you
know they can use that and upgrade it
and then teach and preach promote it
themselves promote it yeah uh uh not
promote it but actually uh help people
understand about yoga because at that
time yoga andbox did not exist
but nonetheless um you know I was uh God
through his Providence showed that I
have to go and do it uh because it'll
add mile age if an Indian presence if an
Indian
Adventist Adventist presence it has a
little bit more legs to stand on yeah
and I can share with you in the
difficulty and and somewhat a fear of uh
having to face uh people in opposition
you know as a prominent yoga teacher in
in the Bay Area um I was lted for being
you know one of the top teachers uh you
know raving reviews about my classes and
people would say to me you've really
transformed my life what they didn't
know was that I was using Christ
principles and attaching it to yoga
ignorantly and so the things that were
happening for them were actually a
blessing from God because he can use
anything in anyone remember he even made
a donkey speak yeah um but once I gained
Clarity on it you know I repented and I
said God tell me what to do and he said
speak to my people and I would go to my
ex- students and I would say you know
I'm so sorry I know that you trusted me
I know that I delivered to you a class
that you enjoyed but what I was
preaching to you wasn't the whole truth
and you need to take a look at this and
every single one of them denied it and
just said but I like it it's okay you
know it's not a problem for me you know
you might believe that but this is what
I do and I was even called Crazy by some
people and a and a hypocrite by other
others um so I can share you know in
that sentiment so since then what has
your life been like oh yeah so since
then uh life um has been amazing I
should say because it's a blessing when
when uh blessing is a blessing amen uh
when the Lord puts a Burden Burden in
our hearts or a responsibility in our
hearts and if we don't execute it then
there is no peace peace until we execute
it there is no peace so we have to
execute what the Lord put in our hearts
and what the Lord has called us to do so
I did resle for a while not to do these
things myself uh because first of all
it's very dangerous even to research
about yoga it's very dangerous you open
yourself up to Spirits 100% yes I found
as well yeah researching you don't have
to do yoga just researching I mean to
some extent you can research on the
surface level yes but as as you keep on
digging and digging and digging and you
enter into uh you know Hindu chanting
and you listen to Hindu music which I
did actually uh it actually affected my
spiritual walk with the Lord so that is
my answer to your question what impact
it had was after a couple of years of
researching on this topic once uh you
know I called my brother there came a
time I called my brother I said I'm not
going to follow Jesus Anymore more no
way I said that I said that in 2018 end
of 2018 I remember I said I'm not going
to follow Jesus anymore I'm going to
become a
Hindu what flipped this the script for
you there is no no specific onoff switch
Yeah that I can remember but all I can
say is because I was constantly
researching on this topic and listening
to mantras and watching videos about it
so what happened was in my mind it just
uh seduced me when I say seduced uh like
spiritually seduced I should say so I
was completely disconnected from God at
that time and I was just Leed without my
knowledge I was just Leed and it felt
good to me it felt good to me but there
was no peace so what I did was I stopped
my Bible studies like I stopped offering
Bible studies I cut
off um you know talking to Adventist
friends no reading the Bible of course
no prayers nothing all I was thinking
was I have taken this path to become a
Hindu and that's what I'm going to
pursue that was in my mind and and all
of this happened like I said just by
researching in depth so it took like
around two weeks or so after that the
Lord spoke to me and I can tell mostly I
can tell when the Lord speaks I can tell
um so the Lord spoke to me when the Lord
speaks there is a sense of peace I'm
sure or you have experienced many of us
have experiened yes indeed when the Lord
speaks and convicts us there's a sense
of Peace joy and happiness love exactly
love there's no fear per se but fear out
of respect but not not the other type of
fear uh you don't get scared no um so
the Lord spoke to me and then the Lord I
felt like the Lord lifted me up from the
quickmire and he drew me out of it and
what that did to me was that a whole
experience I began to empathize Hindus
more I began to empathize Western yoga
gurus and Western yoga practitioners I
began to understand okay so this is
exactly what they go through as well
because they have no idea this is
happening to them and they are drawn
into that quick M and if we go and say
hey it's satanic for example right it's
an insult right it's an insult what do
you mean it's giving me results I'm
feeling better I'm in shape what do you
mean my mind is clear I'm able to focus
on what I want to do but unfortunately
uh most of the world doesn't tell them
the side effects leave alone the
spiritual aspect the side effects the
physical side effects the mental side
effects I regret to have to stop you
here but it is a wonderful high note and
we're going to have you back right
absolutely heart to's coming thank you
for being here second Corinthians
chapter 4 tells us and I quote but we
have renounced the hidden things of
Shame not walking in craftiness nor
handling the word of God deceitfully but
by manifestation of the truth commending
ourselves to Every Man's conscience in
the sight of God for it is the god who
commanded light to shine out of Darkness
who has shown in our hearts to give the
light of the knowledge of the glory of
God in the face of Jesus Christ see you
next time my name's blessings wi and
this has been a wolf in sheep's
clothing
[Music]
[Applause]